the leader of a religious sect in South
Korea at the center of the corona virus
outbreak has apologised for not stopping
the infection from spreading the founder
of the controversial Shin geonji Church
is being investigated for allegedly
trying to cover up infections the Church
in the city of Daegu has been described
as the epicenter of South Korea's
outbreak McBryan is live for us in Seoul
Rob so we've seen an apology of sorts
from the leader of this religious group
what else did he have to say that's
right this has been a long awaited event
the first public statements by the
controversial leader of an even more
controversial Church Lee man he
appearing at a news conference at one of
the church's facilities outside of Seoul
and throughout the whole statement
apologizing profusely for his church's
role at the center of this outbreak even
at the start on a couple of occasions
actually getting down on his knees on
the ground and bowing to the assembled
journalists saying that he it was
something that that he's very sorry
about saying that they are taking now
all possible measures to try to sort
this out he never thought that this
would happen that they are cooperating
completely with the authorities and as
some of some of the church leaders have
said in the past they are the ones that
are bearing the brunt of this they are
the victims if you like because of
course more than half of all of the
cases of the corona virus here in South
Korea are indeed members of this church
now it is regarded by other more
mainstream churches here as more like
acting like a sect and a secretive sect
at that with a number of different
groups here calling on the authorities
calling on prosecutors to investigate
the church for possible charges of
homicide even and also of hiding the
names of its members the church itself
says that it is cooperating fully it's
provided contact details of all of its
members so that the authorities can
follow up and health officials can check
with them to see if air they are
carrying the viruses these numbers can
you too spike but it is very
controversial and in fact it will throw
out - this whole sometimes rather a
rather angry press conference you could
hear the shouts of protesters who have
been besieging this facility and other
branches of this same church robbers you
mentioned the numbers in South Korea are
rising very fast what is the latest well
they've had a further spike - over 4,000
cases now we're still the epicenter is
down in Daegu this city down of the
south east of the country and health
officials are still waiting to see
whether the numbers we are seeing these
daily increases that are still spiking
whether if this is due to maybe still
some of the first infections from the
congregations of the church that were
held a couple of weeks ago and now we're
seeing the end of that incubation period
or whether we're starting to see which
is the worrying trend more secondary and
tertiary infections where whether we're
seeing some of those initial people who
were infected going on to infect other
people thankfully so far as far as the
authorities are concerned most of the
cases are still in the southeast of the
country but it as the authorities keep
on reminding us these next few days are
still very crucial Rob McBride in Seoul
dear thank you